[This film is titled The 1954 Expedition to Southern Sudan in Search of Yellow Fever, by Richard Moreland Taylor and Telford H. Work. NAMRU 3, Cairo, Egypt. The film is silent.]
[Hooded Crow--used in identifying the West Nile virus by the virologists at the Naval Army Research Unit number 3]
[A DC3 carrying scientists and equipment flies over mountains and dry river beds in the Nubian Desert following the Nile River]
[Khartoum appears with a razor-shaped separation between the desert and farmland]
[Flying over several cities]
[Single mast felucca with lateen sails on river White Nile]
[Statue of Horation Herbert Kitchener, Lord Kitchener of Khartoum (1950-1916) on horseback]
[Statue of Maj. Gen. Charles George Gordon (1833-1885) on a camel]
[Men gathering outside tomb of the Mahdi across the river in Ombdurman, a holy center for pilgrimages]
[Street scene]
[Outside the laboratory at the Medical School, men are loading field and laboratory equipment into Jeep]
[Jeep drives up onto a flatbed railroad car]
[Another Jeep drives up with large wooden crate containing a refrigerator]
[The crate is moved near the jeep]
[Another box is moved onto the railroad car]
[Scene of a mobile laboratory wagon]
[Men loading fragile supplies into laboratory]
[Scene of locomotive]
[Water being added to steam locomotive]
[Discussion between two men]
[Man adding oil to wheels of locomotive engine]
[Steam coming out of locomotive engine]
[A flat landscape of short savannah grass with animals is passed]
[From El Obeid, trucks loaded with equipment ride on a sand road to Kasha]
[Round huts found on rocky outcrop]
[Silhouettes of women carrying calabashes filled with water on their heads appear on the road]
[Curious women and children view the newcomers]
[Young warriors wear charms around their necks and carry spears or long sticks]
[Both men and women undergo scarifications for cosmetic purposes]
[Entering the village of Talodi, the truck attracts the curious]
[Dr. Taylor collects blood from children]
[A Galago or bush baby--a little primate with globulus eyes; known as a reservior of the yellow fever virus]
[Grivet monkeys or Guenons are seen]
[Nomadic Baggara or cattlemen follow their herds and gather in the Sudd, an island of swampy vegetation--cattle are mostly Zebu from India]
[Home of Dinka people]
[Wells dug 15 to 20 feet deep to get water for the cattle]
[Cattle are ridden as transportation]
[Guinea fowls appear along the road]
[A Cercopithecus Aethiops, a monkey common to the area was shot and the chest has to be open to get access to the heart in order to collect blood]
[A ferry is taken across the Bar el Arab, one truck at a time]
[Scene of cranes, egrets, sacred ibis, greeshanks, avocets, and stilts feeding]
[Whalehead stork or shoebill stork]
[Two crown cranes]
[Giraffes]
[Thompson gazelles]
[A giraffe pelt drying alongside the road is saturated with insecticide to attract tse-tse flies and kill them]
[The truck returns through Dinka land raising much curiosity]
[Two Marabout storks approach a termite mound and are watched by vultures Baobab tree]
[The Dinka,a Nilotic tribe from Nuba, are building a village using soil extracted from termite mounds, mixed with sand in water pits that will become adhesive when wet.  A human chain delivers the mixture to the mason in charge.]
[A dragon lizard scampers from his abode]
[Some structures are in the process of being completed, continually rubbing and smoothing until the right thickness is obtained]
[More giraffes]
[The DC3 meets the expedition and its cargo]
[DC3 flies over the savannah and the sands and rivers of Khartoum]